[موسيقى]
عاصمة جورج تبليسي ، هناك مدينة يمكن
رؤيتها سيرًا على الأقدام ،
اسمي nestin وهذا هو TVC الخاص بي
منذ ثلاث سنوات ،
وأنشأت Amish موقعًا إلكترونيًا ودليلًا إرشاديًا لمنح
المسافرين الشباب رؤية من الداخل
لأفضل الأماكن التي يمكنهم زيارتها في المدينة
يظهر مزيج التأثيرات الفريد من نوعه على مستوى الشارع
من
حمامات الكبريت التي تأسست عليها المدينة ،
وهي واحدة من الأماكن التي يجب أن تراها الشرطة
قبل أربعة قرون في كنائس جو
والأزقة الضيقة من حقبة ماضية.
مدينة تعرض تاريخها
وليس في أي مكان أكثر من أحد
أسواق لوسي ستريت بين
الحلي والمفارش الكثير من
التذكارات السوفيتية نحن في سوق الجسر الجاف للسلع الرخيصة والمستعملة
أحد مكاني المفضلة في
تبليسي ،
كل ما تراه هنا يذكرني
بماضي بلدي في جورجيا  كانت جزءًا من
الاتحاد السوفيتي لمدة 70 عامًا حتى عام 1991 ، تم وضع
آثار ماضي جورجيا الشيوعي
على الجميع ليروا أن
هذه شهادة دبلوم 1984
بالطبع مكتوبة بكل شيء فيها  الجانب
الروسي لأننا في اتحاد الجمهوريات الاشتراكية السوفياتية ، لكن
تبليسي ليست مدينة تسكن
في مبانيها القديمة المتداعية التي يتم
إعادة تصورها كمواقع عصرية
تمامًا مثل فابريكا مصنع خياطة سوفيتي سابق
تحول إلى واحد من
أكثر المناطق الحضرية سخونة في تبليسي
المساحات هي موطن للمطاعم ، وهي واحدة من أكثر
بيوت الشباب شهرة في المدينة ومتجر الكلاب السوداء ، وهو
متجر مفهوم يضع
جورجيا على الخريطة من خلال أبجدية فريدة من نوعها ،
هذه ورش عمل وكل
ما نقوم به هو الترويج
للأبجدية الجورجية بالنسبة لي ، إنها تبدو جميلة جدًا
مثل قطعة فنية مثل هذه ، نعم ،
ما يجعله فريدًا للغاية هو أن PVC لا تزال
تتخطى حدودها ولكنها أيضًا تتطلع إلى
مزيد من البحث في المستقبل
[الموسيقى]